Deutschland liefert weitere Waffen an
die Ukraine zwei weitere mehrfach
Raketenwerfer Mars Sam 200 Raketen sowie
50 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge vom Typ Dingo
das hat Verteidigungsministerin
Christine Lambrecht mitgeteilt diese
Nachricht an dem Tag an dem auch die
deutsche
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen weitere Solidarität mit der
Ukraine demonstriert indem sie nach Kiew
gereist ist unser Reporter Paul
ronsheimer wird gleich vor Ort mit ihr
ein Interview führen hier kommt sie mit
dem Zug an wird von ukraines Europa
Ministerin Stefania begrüßt und macht
sich dann auf den Weg zum ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski von dem sie den
Orden des Fürsten Jaroslav des Weisen
bekommt den Verdienstorden der Ukraine
ja und jetzt ist sie bei unserem
Reporter Paul ronsheimer Paul
schönen guten Abend Frau von der Leyen
Frau von der Leyen wir kommen gerade
zurück von der Front aus hakif haben
dort eine Stadt besucht wo immer noch
gekämpft wird wo Russen immer noch die
Bevölkerung beschießen und die
ukrainischen Soldaten haben mir gesagt
sie brauchen jetzt Kampfpanzer
Deutschland hat gesagt wir schicken
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge aber eben keine
Kampfpanzer sind Sie dafür dass
europäische Staaten Kampfpanzer hier
liefern ich bin dafür dass die
europäischen Staaten das liefern was die
Ukraine tatsächlich braucht ich habe
heute mit Präsident selensky gesprochen
und er hat eine ganze Reihe von Dingen
aufgezählt die sie brauchen ich finde
ganz wichtig die Ukrainer beweisen ja
dass sie wenn sie die richtigen
militärischen Mittel haben sich
verteidigen können und sie kämpfen
diesen Kampf für uns alle das ist der
Kampf dass die Demokratie siegt und die
Autokratie verliert und deshalb ist es
so wichtig dass Sie tatsächlich all die
militärischen Mittel bekommen die sie
brauchen von denen sie sagen wir
brauchen sie jetzt aber sie sagen sie
brauchen Kampfpanzer also sind sie dafür
das Kampfpanzer sie waren mal
Verteidigungsministerin sie kennen den
Leopard in deutschen Leopard dass der
z.B hergeliefert wird also in irgendeine
Detail Diskussion über Waffentypen will
ich gar nicht gehen
Fahrzeuge wenn das richtige panzerte
Fahrzeuge wenn sie sagen sie brauchen
Kampfpanzer dann sollten wir das ernst
nehmen und sollten Ihnen das liefern sie
haben in den letzten Monaten bewiesen
wir erinnern uns ja die
anfangsdiskussionen im Februar sie haben
in den letzten Monaten bewiesen dass sie
genau wissen was Sie brauchen um ihre
Leben zu schützen und sich zu
verteidigen sie sind dafür Kampfpanzer
zu liefern ich habe in diesen Tagen
viele Frauen erlebt in diesem Gebieten
die euphorisiert waren dass sie befreit
wurden wenn man jetzt an die vielen
Frauen die vielen Menschen denkt die
noch in den russischen besetzten
Gebieten sind und
dort leiden sehr wahrscheinlich was geht
ihnen dadurch den Kopf das ist schau
richtig glaube die die eigene Fantasie
ist gar nicht in der Lage sich dieses
Grauen auszumalen ich habe gestern und
heute lange mit Alena selenska
gesprochen die mir auch noch mal
geschildert hat wie die Familie leiden
wie die Kinder leiden wie tief die
Traumatisierung ist ich bin heute in
irpin gewesen und habe dort gesehen
wieder diese klaffenden Wunden und
Narben in den Gebäuden wo Menschen
wohnen wo man also sehen kann dass die
Russen wahllos wirklich gezielt die
Bevölkerung attackiert haben das ist
einfach schaurig das sind schwere
Kriegsverbrechen und die müssen
aufgeklärt werden sehr getroffen sie
kennen würde mir selensky wenn sie sich
in diese Lage versetzen können Sie sich
vorstellen oder was würden Sie tun wenn
ihr Land wenn Deutschland angegriffen
würde würden sie sich verteidigen mit
der Waffe
ich glaube wir haben alle gelernt in
diesem Krieg in der Ukraine wie wichtig
es ist gut aufgestellt zu sein und sich
verteidigen zu können und
das ist beeindruckend hier zu sehen wie
die gesamte Gesellschaft die ganze
Bevölkerung mobilisiert ist und mit
welcher mit welcher Kraft sie auch immer
wieder Hoffnung schöpfen dass sie und da
bin ich fest von überzeugt dass am Ende
die Ukraine gewinnen wird und Putin
verlieren muss warum sind sie so zu
überzeugt das ist ja auch die Debatte
gerade wir sehen der bundeswehrgeneral
Zorn hat das infrage gestellt die
Amerikaner haben mir heftig dafür zu
kritisiert warum sind sie so überzeugt
dass die Ukraine gewinnen nun erstens
sie haben eine gewaltige Motivation und
das macht ganz viel aus sie wissen genau
wofür sie kämpfen für die Freiheit ihres
Landes während die Russen das wissen wir
aus vielen Schilderungen oft nicht mal
wissen wo sie sind und warum sie dort
überhaupt sind
zweitens die Welt die Freunde in der
Welt tun alles dass die Ukraine die
militärische Unterstützung also die die
Waffensysteme hat die sie im auch
braucht um sich zu verteidigen
drittens wir stützen sie mit aller Kraft
dass sie wirtschaftlich über die Runden
kommen dass sie finanziell auf den
beiden bleiben ich bin jetzt zum
Beispiel heute tief in die Details
gegangen mit Präsident selensky wie wir
es eigentlich schaffen können dass die
Ukraine
nahtlosen Zugang zum Binnenmarkt hat um
selber auch wieder Einkommen zu
generieren und die ganzen Demokratien
dieser Welt stehen an der Seite der
Ukraine weil wir eben wissen wofür sie
kämpfen sie sagen die stehen an der
Seite der Ukraine sie sind dafür
Kampfpanzer zu liefern andere wollen das
bislang nicht das heißt die Ukraine
kriegt diese Unterstützung noch nicht
ganz deswegen noch mal die Frage was
glauben Sie woran liegt das er liegt es
vielleicht auch daran und sie kennen
alle
EU-Regierungschefs haben die immer noch
Angst vor Wladimir Putin und vor den
Drogen haben die Angst vor den Drogen
dass ein Atombomber einsetzen könnte
hören Sie das noch
die Staats- und Regierungschefs haben
keine Angst und sie lassen sich nicht
erpressen und wir wissen auch sehr klar
dass wir unsere Kraft über den starken
Binnenmarkt einsetzen die wir haben
nämlich die Sanktionen und wir sehen
jetzt und das sickert mehr und mehr
durch durch all die Berichte wie tief
die Sanktionen in die russische
Wirtschaft schneiden das ist ja auch
unsere herrengehensweise dass wir alles
tun das Putin ein massiven Preis für das
was er Anrichte zahlen muss und dass
eine Kriegskasse austrocknet langsamer
bei sich aber man hört immer wieder
diese Sorge vor der angeblichen
Atombombe die einsetzen könnte auch dass
das bei Staats- und Regierungschefs eine
Rolle spielt haben sie das gehört
trotzdem dürfen wir uns weder erpressen
lassen noch einschüchtern lassen und ich
glaube das haben die letzten Monate
bewiesen wir stehen eng zusammen niemand
hat mit gerechnet dass die Europäische
Union so entschlossen und so schnell
handelt und ich finde wir können auch
stolz darauf sein was wir geleistet
haben in den letzten Monaten das wird
niemals niemals aufwiegen die Opfer die
die Ukraine gebracht hat und den Mut den
die Ukraine zeigt aber wir können zeigen
dass wir in ihrer Seite stehen und dass
wir mit der gleichen Entschlossenheit
sie unterstützen wie sie im Augenblick
diesen Kampf führen putin ist in den
vergangenen Wochen häufig mit Hitler
verglichen worden halten Sie diesen
Vergleich angesichts der Grausamkeiten
die die russischen Truppen in den
besetzen Gebieten begangen haben für
nachvollziehbar ich halte nichts von
solchen Vergleichen weil jede Zeit
anders ist aber dass es schaurig ist und
schwerste Kriegsverbrechen begangen
werden steht außer Zweifel deshalb
unterstützen wir ja auch dass die
Beweise gesammelt werden dass vom
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof die
Verfahren auch möglich sind das ist ja
die Grundlage unserer Rechtsordnung
unserer gemeinsamen internationalen
Rechtsordnung dass wir dann auch diese
Verbrechen ahnten und zum Schluss es
Putin dafür verantwortlich für viele
Europäer sind die hohen Gaspreise die
Konsequenz auch dieses Krieges was sagen
sie deutschen die jetzt mehrere tausend
Euro mehr bezahlen müssen und Monaten
sich das vielleicht nicht leisten können
was tun sie als E-Commerce
bio-kommissionspräsidentin dafür dass
wir das in den Griff kriegen zwei Dinge
tun wir vor allen Dingen das erste ist
Putin hat Milliarden und aber Milliarden
dadurch verdient dass er zum Beispiel
Gas in die Europäische Union und eben
auch nach Deutschland geliefert hat wir
haben in den letzten Monaten hart
gearbeitet wegzukommen vom russischen
Gas und uns an andere Anbieter unsere
Freunde aus dem Vereinigten Staaten aus
Norwegen zum Beispiel zu beenden und das
ist gelungen wir haben jetzt das
russische Gast runtergebracht von 40
Prozent die es einmal den Anteil hatte
auf 9 Prozent das zweite ist wichtig wir
wissen dass viele elektrizitäts
produzierende Unternehmen im Augenblick
riesige Gewinne machen mit denen sie
niemals gerechnet haben und deshalb
haben wir gestern vorgeschlagen also den
Gesetzentwurf auf den Tisch gelegt für
die Mitgliedstaaten und das Parlament
dass wir diese Gewinne abschöpfen und
die Mitgliedstaaten dadurch in der sind
genau diese Bürgerinnen und Bürger und
Unternehmen die jetzt Hilfe brauchen
auch zu unterstützen das sind ungefähr
140 Milliarden für die gesamte
Europäische Union
wenn wir uns jetzt die nächsten Tage
nächsten Wochen anschauen sie sagen sie
sind dafür dass die Ukraine alles
bekommt was Sie brauchen zu Verteidigung
und um die besetzen Gebiete wieder
zurückzuerobern wenn sie sagen sie sind
dafür dass auch Kampfpanzer geliefert
werden was werden Sie jetzt tun um ihre
ich sag mal ihre Staats- und
Regierungschefs in der EU davon zu
überzeugen dass das Richtige ist nun wir
haben ja schon in den vergangenen
Monaten 2,5 Milliarden durch die
europäische friedensfazilität zur
Verfügung gestellt sie wissen dass die
Europäische Union selber überhaupt gar
keine Waffen besitzt aber wichtig ist
dass wir von der europäischen Seite her
all das tun was man neben den
militärischen Mitteln auch zu
Unterstützung der Ukraine tun muss
nämlich die finanzielle Unterstützung
bisher sind das 19 Milliarden die
letzten 5 Milliarden da hat heute das
Parlament zugestimmt und diese
finanzielle Unterstützung wird auch
weitergehen
das ist ja das was sich die Menschen
fragen ich habe aber gerade ja gesagt
dass wir keine eigenen Panzer besitzen
aber nicht darüber wir können darüber
aber nicht entscheiden und wir können
aber den Staats- und Regierungschefs
dadurch helfen dass wir gemeinsam
finanzieren die die Staaten die bereit
sind militärische Systeme auch zu
liefern aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen
die Ukraine braucht dringend auch
finanzielle Unterstützung sie brauchen
im Schnitt im Monat fünf Milliarden um
das Wesentliche aufrecht zu halten die
Krankenhäuser die Schulen die Soldaten
zu bezahlen oder zum Beispiel die
Polizei aufrechtzuerhalten auch das ist
wichtig in diesem Krieg und da spielt
die Europäische Union eine ganz große
Rolle
letzte Frage vor von allein Wladimir
Putin steht innenpolitisch massiv unter
Druck wenn man hier in der Ukraine die
Menschen fragt denn sagen Sie mir wir
würden uns freuen wenn Putin sterben
würde wenn er sterben sollte würde sie
das persönlich freuen
man sollte sich niemals freuen wenn ein
Mensch stirbt und das gilt für jeden
Menschen aber das
Putin diesen Krieg verlieren muss und
für seine Taten
einstehen muss das ist mir wichtig
glauben Sie dass das jemals passieren
wird dass er vor einem Gericht stehen
wird
ich halte das für möglich
herzlichen Dank Ursula von der Leyen
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
[Musik]